[Musique]
moment de fête de chant et de danse sur
le campus à l'occasion des erasmusdies
étudiant martiniquais antillais et
européen qui échangent pour 21
dispositif d'ouverture sur le monde
je crois que aujourd'hui dans le monde
globalisé où l'on vit avoir ce type de
journée très important parce que il nous
permet de connaître d'autres cultures et
de nous rencontrer entre les Européens
et de pouvoir apprendre les uns des
autres
Erasmus vaste programme d'échanges et de
ses jours qui permet chaque année de
voir la Martinique accueillir des
délégations entières d'étudiants de
toute l'Europe
le but c'est vraiment de pouvoir parler
de tout ce qui est mobilité tout ce qui
est international afin vraiment de se
rendre compte que nos territoires
attirent à l'international nous avons de
nombreuses étudiants internationaux qui
ont choisi de venir étudier ici et puis
on a aussi nos étudiants nos jeunes de
notre territoire qui partent à la
découverte du monde et ses étudiants
martiniquais eux aussi profitent du
dispositif ils en reviennent d'ailleurs
complètement sous le charme je suis
partie dans un endroit complètement
différent
culturellement et au niveau du climat
j'avais aucune famille aux alentours et
c'est vraiment toute seule je suis
arrivé toute seule et c'est un moyen de
grandir
en autonomie développement personnel en
organisation et puis on découvre du
monde aussi donc on s'entraide avec
d'autres étudiants internationaux et oui
on en sort toujours plus fort et plus
grand je sais pas si pour des missions
climatique sinon je plane donc dans la
cadenas mission on avait pour but de
sensibiliser et de faire de la
prévention auprès des locaux
2022 sur le campus durant toute cette
journée de vendredi sur le thème de
l'itinérance des arts autre façon de
voyager